guck nicht auf das scoreboard der sonst
fällt konnte nein junge ich schwöre dir
was ich damit leute was geht hier vor
kranich zusammen mit dem lieben franz
der ziemlich komische dinge macht und
wie schallte ein wenig jobs jump auf dem
bergwerk server und blut geht ich mit
ohne 1 wir haben das ganze hat auch mit
franz gespielt ich weiß nicht was kommt
bei dir meins computer endeffekt dann
checkt er einfach mal rüber und schauen
was da für sich entscheiden kann
entschieden hat ich kann sagen das ist
ziemlich knapp war auf jeden fall us
werke ohne zu viel zu verraten
ich bin locker nein abgestürzt ja so
richtig behindert wenn man so richtig
schnell sein möchte ach so ok ihr die
seiten sind vertauscht
nein letzte block komplett fertig nein
ich werde ich leiden sehen kann was war
das doch klar dass ich gewinnen
das ganze nämlich jetzt spiegelverkehrt
weil ich derjenige bin der annimmt und
das habe ich gerade irgendwie erstmal
checken müssen aber wirklich setzen sie
wenn ja wieso er weicht die map immer
noch nicht kann
was stimmt er hey ich verstehe überhaupt
nicht was daran so schwer film ist ich
weiß nicht ich hab dir einfach erst mal
gespielt aber diesmal gewinne ich hatte
bisher nur
arena gespielt ok uns noch gar keine
mehr von marcella für gut geschlagen
nein ich verliere immer diesen
sprachgebrauch verkannten junge das ist
so crazy weil ihr könnt zwar eine seite
sehen so wie der abstand ist aber man
selbst kann
im kern geht es nicht wenn man selbst
kann einfach nicht drauf schauen okay du
machst einfach die runde auch schon
wieder falsch
wir schauen neuaufnahme effekt kann ich
dazu nur sagen hätte ich jetzt auch
gesagt jetzt kommt meine karte venditti
verlierst bist echt schlecht
naja weil sie ist nein ich war ein
bisschen nervös sei sie ist ein sehr für
beide easy weil das ganze hier ist
identisch dem bums nein abgestürzt
quatsch bist du eh nicht guckt nicht auf
das scoreboard
der samstag konnte nein junge ich
schwöre dir was ist denn das ist auch
nicht mehr das ist doch nicht mehr schön
leuchtet es steht 30 30 da werd erstes 5
hat es ja nicht ob das echt nicht mehr
feierlich
da gibt es zwei stand vielleicht packen
wir jetzt hier mal eine aufholjagd ohne
gleichen aus ich persönlich hoffe ich
sehr
ja warum der dritte jump ist mal richtig
mies da häufig darauf stellt sich erst
mal ab ok ich hab' ich verstehe es nicht
ich bin bei den millionen also ich hätte
zu dir über jump müssen und bei dir das
hier werden müssen ein zimmer problem
das mit ihren zwei mal nicht so frech
disney
das nicht normal dass er bei mir
westlich knappe ja dieses mal deshalb
komme ich auch gerade so gar nicht drauf
klar dass das hier angeblich so schlecht
wenn irgendwas stimmt dann nämlich nicht
franz hat glaube ich irgendwie so den
ein oder anderen kita client installiert
so klappt wie konntest du ich hab ich
habe richtig durchgezogen ist ja auch
richtig mit ich habe richtig
durchgezogen und gott ist die karte
wieder das war die wo ich bisher am
härtesten gefehlt habe
kennst du das
wenn du irgendjemand was zeigen möchtest
sozusagen gebäck web oder sowas auf dem
trampolin und kriegst du davor immer so
richtig wie sie hin
dann springen wir runter das ist
spannend halten was ich so wie man es
ernst abgemacht ausgesehen in der kanzel
in dieser vorführeffekt in der fairkehr
ich mich hat das nicht machst du das
unaufgeforderte das winterfell sagst du
so wie abgesprochen sechs toren ein ok
42 wurde franz oder noch ein wirklich
bezirk hier sicher nicht so nennt na ja
man hat ja schon locker gewonnen und
sonst ja aufnahme nur zwei minuten lang
also richtig und deshalb hatte liebe
franz sich oh nein das geht doch nicht
nachts geht aber wir sind
25 minuten backen bis wieviel bis 88
leute dann macht mir das noch bis 8
musste annehmen
ach wirklich ja okay dann stets jetzt 15
2 1 genau leute ich glaube das wird
nichts mehr
aber ich weiß ja ihr könnt ihr jetzt
schon sehen ob das heute in dem ihr die
länge des videos betrachtet hat die
fresse ich wenn du bis nächste zuschauer
schon wieder als versagen worte
restaurant spielt vor kanzlerin kommt
vergebene chance
aber warum es also beim letzten mal ihr
müsst ihr vorgehen bei mir weil man so
bzw
in der letzten aufnahme er hat maximal
da habe ich manchmal nur somit mit einem
punkt oder so was hab ich immer verloren
oder gewonnen zweimal richtig knapp und
diesmal war ich nicht was das hier
gerade soll tiangong 1
nein nein du auch nicht was da los ist
jack definitiv mal franz video aus damit
ihr wisst dass das hier gerade einfach
nur pech ist damit seit damit freude ich
war nicht das ergebnis aber schon mal
gesagt und schon mal gemacht
warum weshalb wieso ein richtig gemacht
nein ich bin mit psychischer gesprungen
wie sie reckt würde ich dazu sagen wie
sie schließt 7 okay wir machen jetzt
sagt wir machen jetzt bis zum schluss
diese karte weil hier kann ich am besten
okay okay damit mache ich nicht kenne
inzwischen auch ein bisschen du kannst
gar nichts zu tun hatte damit das mal
klar ist wer gleich sehen
na was ich finde das ist auch verdammt
schwierig irgendwie mit mit ihrer es ist
ziemlich schwierig leute mir leid dass
ich dieses video grad nicht seht weil
ich mir so eine scheiße nicht hochladen
ärgerlich check franz video aus das ist
definitiv
schaut euch an und jo dann ich bin gar
nicht so schlecht ich habe gerade
einfach nur irgendwie aufmüpfig habe
aufnahmen meines jahren hier ist ein
grüner drache böseste kühlkissen drache
im gegensatz zu dir spaß sie weiß was
gemeint
das macht doch keinen sinn also was
coach ins gesicht ganz matches